hi I'm Anna Kendrick and this is my  glamour cover shoot  Oh God um I think I would rather have my  diary published because I haven't kept  Diaries since I was about 16 and that  entry was like the most embarrassing  entry was about like what it would  eventually be like to have I could seem  like very wet all the time I'd be in  business  I think Graeme check stub my toe oh my  god  paper cuts and like when you bite the  inside of your mouth I can't I can't I  can't or when you get something really  stuck in your eye like the sensitive  bits I can't deal with stub my toe every  time Keira Knightley is a deep obsession  of mine so I'm gonna have to say Keira  Knightley's version of um Elizabeth  Bennett although I get to eat a lot more  pizza if I was very